and i
i'm live by the way oh hey yeah um
uh yeah look i will say there is some
technical issues on something with with
my internet i don't know maybe i have to
call my provider i don't know what's
going on
um
it's like look but
here's the thing with you guys i wasn't
going to do it in the middle of the
podcast i felt like it was better just
to go ahead and do it now than to do it
while we're doing the podcast i'll
probably do stream yards for a couple
weeks until i figure out exactly what's
going on uh because stream yards is
seems to pretty pretty reliable in a lot
of scenarios uh but we'll get that taken
care of later uh you know welcome to the
attic show where we talk about the past
present and future of gaming i got my
co-host with me hustle and motivate
what's going on hustle having some
technical issues dealing with this
um
i don't want a virtual back hey look at
this been so long since i've used stream
y'alls oh here we go now we're fine
everything's cool um if you haven't done
so make sure y'all check out my last
live stream i did it monday i'm just i'm
doing a live stream every saturday now
um
everything's been cool just dealt with
some personal stuff last week
just kind of wrapping that stuff up now
that's why i'm here today and i feel
good i feel really good i'm still
playing kingdom hearts at it i'm
probably gonna stream it no more though
i'm still playing that i promise
you streaming it anymore
it started to feel like work and i don't
want nothing to feel like work
that's all yeah it just felt like work
all right i hear that and then we got
the uh we got my friend i've had for a
few years man we got tim dawg how are
you doing tim dawg
it's all right just got off of work
happy to be here or uh you know i got a
good little show here going on and uh
you know we got a lot to talk about
yeah we do we definitely have a lot to
talk about today man it's it's been a
very eventful weekend gaming may i had i
i think we could all agree on that uh so
you know
as you guys could see we have
some some good topics for you guys you
know i don't know exactly what we're
going to talk about first i feel like
the best thing to talk about first would
most likely be
uh you know look i think we're going to
leave the star field for a little bit
later on the show because you know i
think that's the key focus that
everyone's got here the thing that i
think we're going to talk about first
is that god of war 2022 and whether or
not it's coming out this year you know
for those of you that's seen i i have on
occasion jumped out the window when it
come to this game getting delayed um it
does
look like this game's probably coming
out now it's not confirmed obviously
i do feel like there's a good chance
that it's coming out this year because
of how they're moving
um for those who don't know they
actually are hiring some people in
marketing right now
so
that can mean either way that doesn't
necessarily mean that this game is
coming out right now
it just means that
they're looking for people for in
marketing to help push doubt this
product which as you can ask both the
people on this panel i'm sure
hiring
can be very time consuming
so we don't know exactly
how long it's going to take to get this
individual and we don't know exactly
what it means that they're doing it now
wouldn't you guys agree on that
yeah but i figured like day in the home
stretch um if you're hiring for the
marketing and promotion of something
i kind of feel like the game is done at
this point and i don't know if you you
guys have been paying attention on
twitter but every so often we'll get
these tweets from just different people
who work with sony santa monica and
they'll just on occasion like hey me and
my daughter played this thing i can't
wait for god of war that's all the
rollout the rollout everything's a rollo
first and foremost but all that's a roll
though man and i'm glad
hey listen to flame in the chat too eric
something something maybe wrong with
your audio um but i'm kind of yeah yeah
i'm glad everything is like kind of
rolling at least something at least this
won't get delayed this year unlike a
couple other games that we'll talk about
you know and later on in the pod but
you know i mean we need something you
know something new i prefer to have
something new this year that's all i'm
saying
how you feel tim
i i honestly feel it's gonna hit um from
what i've heard from people
that are pretty good sources that have
pretty good sources within sony
um they're here and they're they're
hitting their uh spots so i'm gonna say
it's uh more than likely it's gonna hit
question to you guys do you think that
i honestly feel like
it's a very good year for sony they're
able to pop out
in terms of uh first party
papa horizon forbidden west
um
their racing game whatever that game is
called gran turismo gran turismo and god
of war all in the same year i feel like
that's a very
very solid year for playstation don't
you guys agree
oh yeah
and this is why it's important for
playstation to
say uh
seize the moment you know the ball is in
their court so to speak um
this i i if i'm a sony fan which i kind
of am i would love for all of that to
happen because like the perfect way you
cap the year off is that you start you
start off strong and then you know even
if you don't you know work the way
through the middle like you just give a
little bit of an appetizer but you got
to make sure you finish strong with one
of the most anticipated anticipated
playstation titles pretty much of last
generation for the sequel coming up this
generation so i think it's cool for them
and i'm
it look like it's going they're going to
hit they stride that's what it looks
like right now
yeah people in the chat are bringing up
uh they did have ghost wire tokyo and uh
for spoken forgot about those games
look uh for spoken looks okay
for someone that i don't want to play
that yeah
i think i i think i'd rather
like i don't know i don't even have like
a weird analogy right now maybe
maybe like what what's that thing happen
when you like
remove your eyeball was that like
oh no i don't know i don't know whatever
it is uh i think i'd rather remember my
eyeball than play that for spokane it
looks pretty i look i'm not saying it
looks like a bad game it just doesn't
look very appealing to me
i don't know about you guys but you know
but regardless what it is sony still
went above and beyond to make sure that
their player base had that and i think
that you know what i want to ask tim
dawg too i feel like microsoft needs to
improve
on that third party content stuff like
look
i want first party and i think first
party is extremely important but i think
at this point we've gotten to see
that sony with this third party
these third party deals these timed
exclusives it's doing oh it's doing a
very big number to microsoft because
sure god of war
forbidden west is big but i think we've
gotten to the point where these third
parties that they've probably secured
is hitting
just as hard as some of their other
first party stuff what do you think
about that tim dawg do you think that
they need to really focus a little bit
more on that third party aspect that you
know get some titan exclusives i think
that you know everyone could really
appreciate that
yeah like they should really go out and
buy activision i mean if they're
available you buy apples
i i think that you look at the situation
xbox is going to take a different tact
than sony uh they're not going to look
for short-term
exclusive deals windows phil has always
said he's not about that
what they will do is what you saw
earlier in the year they'll buy a whole
entire third-party publisher and knock
the socks off the world and that's
exactly
uh what if they if they can do that they
will
um if they can get a pass
as we know right now it's in
litigation whatever you want to call it
a regulation
um but i just think there are two
different companies with two different
mindsets i think xbox rather have
the whole kit and caboodle within their
stack
and
it from there
verse the way sony's doing it with these
one year to two year exclusives now they
are very
uh you know they like you said they are
they are definitely um
an advantage and they're doing good i
just think like xbox is a different way
of going about it uh than sony i don't
think that xbox even though they should
at this point
um as we'll go into the further show
when we get to the delays
uh maybe they can get some type of
third-party deal with the triple uh with
a triple-a third-party vendor for game
pass um
but i don't really think that that
that's like i said uh to reiterate i
think that they rather
uh actually buy the third party and make
it themselves and you know just have
such a
robust third party uh first party where
you don't really need third party in any
capacity
uh you know obviously it's a joke right
now they're not there but uh in their
ultimate vision you know uh if you're
you know distributing five games triple
a's a year or four triple a's a year you
really don't need that
and i agree with you on everything i do
feel like
uh
microsoft's gonna approach stuff
different because they have something
like game pass and instead of going out
and securing timed exclusives that
probably cost a lot more money it would
make more
like
sense considering their the the way they
structure their business to go after
timed exclusive
game pass deals i do agree with you on
that but there's one thing i will push
back a little bit on 10 dog is i do feel
like because of stuff like final fantasy
7 remake persona 5 you know all these
games that sony's went above and beyond
to secure because they don't make those
games anymore i do feel like you know
and for spoken uh don't want to forget
that that maybe microsoft maybe not
necessarily go after the big aaa stuff
uh
be a little more aggressive getting
those games on your platform but go
after more of something that kind of
like nintendo does where the triangle
strategies the octopath travelers maybe
get those games exclusive as a time
thing going into game pass and to be on
your console exclusive because i do feel
like in terms of that japanese market
that china market that market that's not
the american or even europe to a point
they're failing in that kind of lack and
in the in the masses that they kind of
want so i feel like you know i agree
with you on like the big the western
stuff but i do feel like maybe they need
to be a little bit more
strategic and spend a little bit more
money in terms of exclusivity when it
comes to that eastern market that timed
exclusives on like the final fantasies
what do you think on that tim do you
think maybe that's an area that they can
broaden their horizons and not
necessarily do stuff that
makes sense to us in terms of their
model with game pass
oh yeah no you make a good point listen
in the end of the day they they don't
they're not up to par with what sony
offers as far as their jrpgs and
personas and and the deals that they
have um and that's uh because you know
sony's always been aggressive where xbox
you know you take some of these
third-party uh jrpgs
you know they come to sony by default
and xbox has to make a play
and spend money to get them just to
release it on their platform and that's
if they'll do it the third party
so uh a hundred percent yeah they are
behind uh
and i think that um
they actually have looked in japan
and they are they are starting some
stuff but they're way behind but uh i
know phil had wanted to get a japan
studio for the longest time um but for
whatever reason they've met resistance
they've having kind of uh fulfilled
their
uh you know prophecy there i mean we had
phil go out there for a while
make some deals and um we had some you
know some things here and there but
listen this this platform still doesn't
have atlas games still doesn't have
persona
um and there's some gaping holes there
that uh if they want to be serious in
the jrpg and the japanese and asian
market like you said
they got to be uh more uh involved there
now
i'll say this much you know
e3 is coming around the corner maybe
they have some surprise for
us i do know that sarah sarah bond
is more value of values i believe more
of the
traditional jrpgs and
and those type of games more than phil
um and i do think that she has a strong
playing hand with this
uh so i do think you will see a little
bit of a better
output but um until we start seeing
persona
and you know maybe even final fantasy
vii i can't believe it's still not on
xbox
uh even after two years it's gonna be
um
you really have to say that they're not
doing their job there and they're always
gonna be
you know not even second fiddle third
fiddle
and uh i don't know i mean for me
my outlook always on on japan has always
been bleak so i don't know what they can
do i remember in the 360 er they went
really hard but you know they they
probably had maybe a five percent
uh you know uh cut through you know they
didn't really do well they didn't do as
well as they had to do
and if they try that again i don't know
if they would get the results that they
would want i do believe
um
that the xbox is recognized as a western
console and there are some things there
that that you know kind of
uh don't feel as home as as maybe as
sony or nintendo does in japan and i
think that's a problem that they have to
get past or try to get past but it's
it's a it's a dubious problem for them
i agree and um
you know definitely want to push it to
hustle let him give his response on that
i uh i personally feel like
everyone's not gonna take sony i mean
microsoft seriously in that lane unless
you know they get those timed exclusives
or even maybe make a fresh jrpg studio
from from the ground up maybe now since
they have uh the studio that they got
with bethesda um trying to remember its
name
uh
someone help me oh tango yeah tango
maybe they have a little more wiggle
room that they can actually do something
more in japan how do you feel about the
hustle do you think that uh you know
microsoft needs to be a little bit more
aggressive in terms of the jrpg market
or the japanese market in general
uh man absolutely if that's the one area
that you're lacking then as far as
getting the eastern audience
you know get the games they like i mean
it's it's not a thing um i think tim
dawg had just brought it up
yeah um final fantasy vii i forgot it
was out and yeah it's not on xbox yeah i
didn't think it's on p no it's on pc
right and then on pc but it's not all
next i think it's everywhere with xbox
pc yeah yeah so i mean so that was that
that's the whole mixed up with them too
and if you ordered like a special
edition because i don't know if y'all
remember but they did have like a didn't
they had like best buy had like a
special box collector's edition on
playstation and xbox or am i wrong i
know i'm not wrong here because i know i
tried to buy one
out of the way you haven't got me
i think they've had some things where it
was crossed over where it's always been
teased
but you know you know it was kind of a
foregone conclusion that it was going to
come after the year of supposed
exclusivity but like you said i mean
i've seen stuff like that too it just
never came to fruition and now
well i think we're at two years and if
it's at two years
it's i would say pretty bleak okay and i
didn't want to say this i kind of wanted
to mention this we we just saw square
get rid of their uh western
restaurant studios
so it's rumor it's heavily wrong with
that sony may be announcing an
acquisition for square soon if they
announce that acquisition then it goes
through
does xbox with xbox fans still be able
to get final fantasy 7 is it like an
obligational thing that they have to
agree to or is it because if you haven't
gotten it now
if sony buys them would you even get it
at all would you even get that game at
all i guess that's my question
i think part of me feels like
sony look here's just mine
let me put let me put the um
the conspiracy cap on
uh
i feel like sony and square enix have
been talking for a while about a
possible purchase
and i feel like
i feel like sony is about to buy square
enix i don't know why part of me feels
like there's a reason that they
separated their western market
especially at guard as the galaxy uh was
occur it wasn't a commercial success but
i do think that it does well enough to
justify more progress with that kind of
brand i feel like they cut them because
they know that
that margins up their price point and i
think they're trying to sell to sony um
i'm not saying that they did anything
intentionally with xbox to
not
entice sony to not buy them but i do
feel like there might have been like a
okay you know we work with us to work
with you i think it's one of those
things where it's like you know maybe
the reason we ain't seen final fantasy
is because
square enix kind of knows that the
sequels aren't going to be
on xbox and even if they put the first
one on xbox
like square enix those are about to be
bought and they've probably known for a
while
and that's the reason they're not very
aggressive with putting it on xbox now
when it comes to octopath traveler
stuff that they publish i think that's
different they know they're going to
make money from that because
those things aren't going to have
sequels and stuff uh
if you look at it from a standpoint we
ain't heard nothing about the next
dragon quest being coming to xbox wayne
heard nothing about any final fantasy 16
14. um
all the final fantasies have left game
pass now and guess where they are
they're on playstation plus
uh so
it is what it is if they buy them they
buy them and it's the same mentality i
had when it comes to bethesda
you get to keep the spoils of war and
they won that that uh encouragement with
buying square enix
uh you know
tim dawg do you think there's a realm
where
sony buys square enix
um um to be honest i don't know the
recent comments were
um pointing in the other direction but
uh it obviously seems like um
the most logical decision and and it
does seem like you guys are saying i
feel the same way it is going to
eventually happen
um
so i don't know i think it's 50 50 but i
do think that
uh these timed exclusive deals
either way
uh either way sony's going to be
in real solid position with spear enix
to where they get these exclusives and
that's not going to stop so whether they
are purchased and they're in the in
their home studios or if they
are just a you know a silent partner
where they
you know
they keep these games off off of xbox it
has the same direct result and you know
you look at final fantasy vii never came
to xbox final fantasy 16.
i doubt they say it it's a a year
exclusive but that could just be for pc
and you know it could be that you know
they you know being that they know that
they're so close and
possibly you know they know down the
road that there might be a purchase
that
that's just going to be even more of an
incentive for them to
to kind of keep this
exclusivity the way they're doing it
whether it's time two years or
uh you know uh one year i mean you're
looking for spoken it's two years
so uh
i think they're the logical partner and
i do think that it's just a studio that
either or
you look at sony's portfolio that
they're going to have a strong
presence there and and when you look at
xbox's portfolio you're going to see a
lacking presence so i think that's going
to continue no matter what you
purchased or not and uh let me pick it
back up some more quick edit before you
before you jump in
um yeah xbox sadly has never had a
presence in japan so if i'm square no
matter how much money microsoft would
offer me
i still wouldn't take it because like
they ain't going to get no like real
return on that or like i got a feeling
those numbers would be down
excuse me addict i know
i know you like the jrpgs
but you will you you my friend are like
one and like
let's say the average 10 xbox fans
and i'm being generous when i say that
so like nah like you know when i when i
see something like this like like a
kingdom of hearts
you know i bought that based off of your
recommendation but like
a lot of people not they're not going to
do that they just want to play halo
gears unfortunately i'm just going to
keep a guido with you they're not
they're not going to care i agree with
you in terms of maybe jrpgs aren't as
popular as they are on like other
platforms
on xbox but
if you want to build a service like game
pass you want to expand it to other
regions such as china japan
you are going to have to pursue these
avenues
because just because the western
audience don't want these don't mean
other audiences that you expand to is
not going to want it would you say uh
tim dawg
yeah especially when you look at
the
possibilities with cloud and touch
gaming
jrpgs are perfect for
cloud gaming you know you don't really
need that much they're not fast-paced
games a lot of them are turn-based
uh some of them you could probably play
all by touch
so uh
you know maybe
outside the pocket outside the the
you know um box here
that they definitely can try from that
person you know even if they get the the
games that way on the platform
i think it's a smart thing i i just
think that it's smart
to even even if you're spending money
and i know i know i think
they don't like doing that that they
believe it's a third party's um
duty to kind of distribute
you know uh
evenly
but when you know 15 people are buying
it on xbox and 3 000 are buying it on
sony you really can't complain with
third party and in a way you have to
make it incentive sentence size
for that third party to release their
game so they have to
uh
they have to some way somehow
make it where they can get these games
on i don't know if uh
you know they they could
uh allocate some budget but it's just
smart to have these jrpgs on the system
regardless of
uh even the low the low pair comes
because i do think it can grow into
something and i do think it's something
where
you know if you're a gamer and you have
an adequate amount of jrpgs
you say okay i'll stick with xbox
you know i don't really you know have to
go and just i'll stick to them primarily
but let's say you are a gamer and you
get no jrpgs
you might be swayed to say you know what
screw this
this is [ __ ] and i'm going to go to
sony and
i've seen that with some people
you know stuff like that can sway people
so you have to consider everything even
though if it's just not straight in your
face you have to consider every kind of
you know buying points that you can get
and i just think it's smart business to
have a jrpg presence
and and and japanese presence on on the
platform
uh you know for a bunch of reasons
xcloud being
a big one and it's like i said at the
end of the day
game pass is a very
profitable thing
if they do it right if you only worry
about the western and some of the
eastern
regions and you know you only worry
about you know are we going to do good
in europe i feel like
you're you're you're hurting your growth
but if you
i don't think i personally feel like the
best way to succeed in this is to make a
couple studios that make these type of
games but if that's not something that's
realistic and they don't want to put the
kind of money into that because that's
expensive
but i feel like
we've seen over and over again in the
past and i know we've kind of went a
little bit away from the god of war
thing
uh but you know it's a good conversation
i'll let it go uh it
to me you need to show
the eastern developers you need to show
them look
we respect your culture we're investing
into it we're putting money back there
because we we've seen you know phil
spencer saying interviews i can't 100
rock with the xbox brand but i don't
even see it in my own stores that often
i don't see it probably prominent my own
stores and they that's what they're
saying to him
publicly
privately
you know there's going to be a lot more
why am i rocking with xbox when they
don't even own an old studio here why am
i rocking with the xbox when they're not
investing into our market
because when you're not paying people
like sony to make games for you uh you
know you timed exclusively i guess you
could count that but i i wouldn't uh you
know i feel like investing into a
culture
is starting
a studio there employing people to work
there
paying people well there paying people
to work in your studio there i feel like
that is what's going to get eyes when
people are like yo
xbox is paying good money let's go work
there they got their own studios here
that's why i feel like sega is a very
profitable thing for them to purchase
because i feel like owning sega would it
would start waves people would be
enticed to do stuff
and especially when you're starting to
not poach but be better places to work
than the places around you in in japan
you know what i'm saying does that make
sense uh uh tim
yeah it makes sense to me a hundred
percent
uh that's kind of my point like what i
was saying
uh you know it was kind of like what i
felt like some some of these
you know unwritten rules or whatever the
case you wanna say i would say the show
when the show wasn't on xbox
a lot of people would say i'm not
rocking with the xbox it doesn't even
have baseball on it you know and uh i
think that's kind of like a little bit
similar to this
where you know if you're not even you
know showing any kind of
presence you know you could turn off
people and you can you know you could
just take even somebody who just has you
know
they just want to have some rpgs or
jrpgs in there in their you know in
their catalog and when you're not having
any it's like you know
it definitely could hurt your business
so
i think it's in their best interest to
have a better
i think obviously was we were
reiterating for them to do better here
but we've been saying this for how long
and i just don't know how fruitful
the conversation is over there oh yeah
and i agree and like i think that's one
of the reasons that's made playstation
so successful was they was
successful on that side of the world and
they did it over here
like
they focused because they're like we got
our home good
let's focus over there let's make them
games they want over there uh let's
let's make the uncharters and if you
really think about it a lot of their
core
audience has moved away from the
japanese thing like you know naughty dog
uh god of war these aren't really
eastern type of games they're western
audience games
and i think that's what's made
playstation so successful is they look
we have our partners we have square enix
we can reach out to we can get this part
fine
let's go over there and work on god of
war let's get the western audience on
the board and i think that's what's very
been beneficial to them but let's go and
get this uh this ten dollar super chat
real quick get a ten dollar super chat
from
donna taku i bet you were surprised i
missed i pronounced that correctly
aren't you
final fantasy xv
tells the verizon scarlet next six are
examples of xbox versions having higher
attach rates of copy so to amount of
consoles compared to the ps4
so it's not like xbox is hopeless now
okay fun fact
i didn't know that those games sold more
uh i'm gonna take his word for that
loosely because i'm not gonna look that
up in the middle of the podcast
he didn't say sell more he said that
it's basically
it's selling more on xbox than other
games that would have uh you know what's
interesting about those games uh hustle
and tim dawg
scarlet nexus is a very successful jrpg
tales of verizon is a very successful
jrpg and final fantasy xv is a very
successful jrpg
i would put like kingdom hearts 3 in
there
a lot of the times we get not the bad
jrpgs but like the middle average tiers
the ones that people like but not
they're not the defying
definitions of what this genre can
provide there are no personas there are
no
dragon quests there are no final fantasy
7 remakes the ones that are doing
extremely well
but when you do see the good ones come
out they sell well and that's where i
always point out
microsoft has to do better making sure
these games come to the platform because
when you do you start seeing games like
this succeed more because you're getting
the ones that people like and they're
willing to branch off and try other
games
uh someone said uh idiom just dropped on
game pass it did
that's cool i'm sorry is it dragon quest
on game pass it is and that i'm not
talking about the games dragon quest
came out like two years before it came
out on game pass
they talk about dragon quest 11 right
yes okay when dragon quest 12 hits game
or hits
hits xbox game date then we can have
this conversation those are the kind of
games that we need to see come on game
pass before we get that now we're going
to reel this conversation back a little
bit to the point of the conversation
which was the god of war 2022
is confirmed and it's not necessarily
confirmed we're just seeing a lot of
proof saying it's coming out this year
it's good i think auto war is going to
do very good i think it's going to push
sony into a very good 2022.
uh the question i have for the for the
panel real quick before we move to the
next topic is
what does this mean for xbox if god of
war comes out do you think that
maybe it's a good thing that starfield
did get pushed back
on a
standpoint that it could cannibalize
it in general because if you look at
stuff like this like successful games
coming around of other successful games
have hurt
games extremely
well like if you look at
her
horizon for ben west that game came out
eldon ring came out no one talked about
horizon anymore so if god of war does
come out and it's towards the end of the
year around the time that maybe
starfield would have dropped do you
think it would be better for starfield
to come out
towards the beginning of next year where
it's away from god of war completely
let's start with hustle hustle how do
you feel about that
no no no no no see we can't roll like
that because i had another example in my
mind right you remember my fallout 4 i
think it was fallout 4 on rise of the
tomb raider came out at the same time
and they had that big clash
um no
xbox needed to drop something like that
to in order to compete hey look i mean
we're not saying i'm not referring to
competing i'm referring to
star fields health in general not xbox
but the starfield brand like it would
have it would have gone fine at least
like a month and a half
around god fought i mean uh god of war
let's be real that could have heard it a
little bit i'm not saying it would have
been the end-all be-all but i'm saying
me as someone that wants starfield to do
well
i'm kind of relieved that that's not in
the 2022 gate man i'm not trying to have
starfield get cut in half by kratos
regardless how i feel about kratos i am
willing to say that
god of war is a big brand they're not on
the platform sure i see people in the
comments section saying that
but god of war is a huge game uh
i'm aware i'm aware this is a very big
franchise i'm away i had to re had this
resurgence back in 2018. i'm well aware
that it wouldn't have it wouldn't have
got in the way it definitely wouldn't
have gotten in the way of what starfield
is because well we kind of don't know
what star field is but if if it is what
we think it is it says fallout in space
that's not the same as is what kratos
sent them adore that's not the same
so it's appealing to two demographics
but it is one of those scenarios where
look this isn't the same thing sure
but it is two big games and i will and
i'm willing to bet because if someone
had to choose between both of them
obviously game pass exists so it gives
it a little bit easier for starfield to
sell will not necessarily sell but it
gets easier for them to breathe i will
say that if it came between both of them
because regardless money is a currency
but you know what else is a currency
time
god of war isn't going to take as much
time as a game like star field but if
people are willing to pick that up
around the holiday which is around that
november time man black friday
they might choose god of war because
it's a well-known ip over something new
like star field so to me as a starfield
fan and want that game to do well
i'm actually happy that they delayed it
out of the god of war
area now sure
is that going to mean that if it came
out and they both competed in the same
time frame wouldn't it mean one would do
better than another one that's debatable
we don't know exactly what star ills yet
we'll have to talk about that after we
see the game play but to me
i don't want starfield nowhere near that
god of war i'm gonna be real with you
what do you think about that tim
i don't think that they really would
would be hurting each other one because
they're on the same platform uh they're
both exclusive uh
xbox also has pc
um and that's you know it's not like
it's not like the small pc crowd it's
like the enormous pc crowd that comes
out to pay
uh fallout 4 even though it was an
existing ip
sold 12 million
copies within the first
24 hours or 48 hours
uh
you know took took i think el during
three weeks to do that
so um i was reading that today earlier
so you're dealing with a huge ip on both
ends
um i do believe that they wouldn't they
wouldn't affect each other because
they aren't like i said they're
exclusive anybody who has an xbox
is going to get it and anybody who has a
sony playstation is going to get it
they're not going to say oh or if
they're both owners they're not going to
say oh i have you know god of war i
don't have to play star field totally
different games
um
if you have an rpg itch you know and you
you know that and you're when you're
playing god of war you're not going to
be happy what i mean
uh so
so at the end no i don't think it hurt
it i think that it was you know we'll
get into it was it it was
from an optics point of view it was a
really big miss uh from a morale point
of view it's a really big miss and um
you know if they had their druthers
you know if they could have kept one
and just one and that includes forza if
they had starfield sitting there
you wouldn't see the type of stuff that
you've seen that that transpired over
the week
um because it is a competitive
thing here there are you know regardless
of what you say or anybody says
uh not you per se but just you know when
you talk about this
people do
judge it and compare it
and the fact that sony has a huge triple
life and they're sitting home free
and xbox been in this position many
times and xbox fans
have pushed this
to odd ad nauseum that hey sony is dry
and they just got marketing deals
and you know
they're they're in trouble and xbox has
to make a move here
uh the shoes on the other foot this time
and it's it's definitely bitter speed
this sweet because
i don't think anybody thought that this
game was going to get delayed i think
as i said on our
txr
i believe phil went to to
to
um
you know uh
the east coast where we're there in
baltimore i think
and he went to their headquarters
and he asked what's going on with the
game and uh
todd looked at him
peter hines looked at todd and they both
sat down and said we got bad news
and i think that that's what happened so
uh this news i think was sudden
to fill and you know people could say
well why was he more on top of this
i've said this
many times
especially with with a studio like
bethesda
uh phil has been hands off with those
type of studios because
they've been doing this for a long time
and
they could you know handle them
under his logic they could handle
themselves
uh you know uh they don't need they
don't need their hands held
and uh you know
unfortunately
uh all bets didn't pay off and that's
where they got you know uh we'll talk
about that later and we're gonna talk
about it whenever we get to it but it's
definitely a big thing but yeah the fact
that that that god of war is there and
and star wars and star stuff fields not
is absolutely huge
i agree with you uh and one thing you
know i will say
microsoft knew they're gonna get a lot
of backlash for this and i will respect
them
because they delayed it it would have
been easy for them to come out the game
be a little bit buggy
uh you know depending on what condition
it was
and they value having games out this
year overvalue the state of the games
when they came out
and i got to respect microsoft because
they they're like no
push this we're not going to have this
come out be buggy whatever the reason
they push this
this can come out later we can take the
flack we could take the heat that's fine
we value
the image of that game over the image of
xbox and that's literally what they
chose
they chose the image to make sure
starfight came out the best it can be
over the state of the game itself and uh
and i i i respect that so we gotta find
out super shot from dawn otaku
why are we still talking about xbox not
doing enough in japan when they've
invested 200 plus japanese studios
through id at xbox
no one's
really saying that now i will say that's
a very good opening part because
the next generation of developers that
take the reins after the current people
that are retiring
that's those 200 plus people when
they're done with whatever they're doing
or they move on or they become or they
grow into bigger studios than they are
now because of programs such as id at
xbox
they're gonna have a lot better say in
oh xbox was there for me when i was down
let's say some of them go to to scoring
they said they don't get bought
they're
they're in good positions xbox was there
for me when i was down they helped me
get that game out and that's a very good
standpoint and a good opening place for
them to beat
um
i think and then we got another five
dollar supervision from donald
only game starfish should be afraid of
is breath of the wild too ragnarok would
get bodied by starfire like horizon was
but
i disagree
i disagree look bad mm-hmm don't talk
who they might be on to something man
you might be honest don't listen to
addict
i'm trying to save you from
embarrassment we appreciate the
donations we definitely appreciate you
know the donations but uh god of war is
a little bit different craig kratos is a
little bit different from a lloyd i'm
just saying we just want to keep it a
buck
star phil got man star forgot that that
sniper man what's that chick anna from
overwatch man she's like
it's a joke man it's all jokes all right
so let's go and move on man we got this
playstation plus detail so those you
know we've been saying playstation now
is is horrible it's not a good service
and we saw
the results of that through the actual
subscription service itself never really
got a lot of people subbing to it it
does look like uh you know
watched a couple weeks ago they actually
changed a lot of that around uh they're
merging playstation now and playstation
plus uh you know like i say it they're
actually finessing you guys and paying
more for the same service that you had
with playstation now but you know let's
get into a little bit on what the actual
service is now how many of you guys saw
uh you know we're not gonna go too much
into the actual service itself but how
many of you guys saw
the screen itself
like the the upgrades
you mean like the ubisoft thing
yes how many of you guys saw that also
the classics
so here
here is the
the updates in general uh so it does
look like they're being a lot more
aggressive in terms of their own stuff
which we've said this for a minute like
tim dawg i remember we saying this
forever
why is it these games that are already
out on playstation now
something such small something so small
that these games don't realistically
make them a lot of money anymore why
aren't they in that looks like they've
been listening to us man
um you know they're adding ps5 and ps5
catalogs bloodborne which i'm pretty
sure bloodborne was in the playstation
collection games wasn't it
um yes bloodborne was already there
demon souls
uh so we're focused
uh we're focusing on adding high quality
tiles to the playstation plus service
for people to join i'm pleased to share
a selection of cons that will be
available on playstation plus extra and
premium so that's i'm pretty sure the 15
and the 18 tier if i remember i don't
know maybe yeah the middle ten maybe
it's the 10 and 15. i don't know the two
tiers that's not the basic playstation
playstation.com will be updated with the
game list when it launches
so
bloodborne concat genie day's gone which
i'm pretty sure day's gone and
bloodborne was already in the collection
for playstation plus but it's still cool
yeah demon souls game that just came out
so that was the launch title that's good
yep destruction all-stars which i'm
pretty sure that was a playstation plus
uh everybody's golf i don't know if
that's been there goes to shiva
director's cut
uh is that i don't think that's in the
that might be in the collection i don't
know
uh private rush god of war they've been
very fickle with that having that come
on
god of war has uh been there it's it's
been in the place if you're on the ps5
and you have the playstation plus
collection god the war was one of those
ones that's been there as well
milo spider-man miles morales
man hey kremlin well i don't know if
that game is underrated but if you
haven't played it and you have this
service please play please let's buy the
man y'all it's so much fun it's so good
so it's look like uh medieval uh i know
that game isn't too returnable
yes
that was a big one see i didn't see this
list i saw the ubisoft uh email that
came out i didn't see this
that that to me is uh
man like yo when you i guess you got to
strike when the irons had because they
they did their numbers or whatever the
numbers that they're going to do i don't
think they pushed a million per se but
having that there now is kind of saying
a lot and you know you know as we all
know sony just purchased
um how's mark almost said how's monkey
somebody just purchased house to mark so
that so that's good to see that that
game is gonna have uh
longer legs or extra life so to speak
with the new addition with the dlc and
everything that it just got with the
endless tower and the co-op gameplay so
that's good to see yeah shadow colossus
uh the last guardian both the last uh
the last of us uh the dlc and the
original remake
until dawn by supermassive great game
that was always that was always there as
well
all the charges it looks like yup
damn okay because it wasn't like that at
first good that's good to see we got
third party uh partners action
uh assassin's creed van holler that's
not too old
uh city skylines we got uh dead cells
which i think's been on game pass
multiple times
hold on hold on hold on you skip on
celeste we we have celeste
you got to pay that respect that's good
that's right
uh we got the far cry three and 4 uh
final fantasy 15 royal edition like i
said scoring this game just popping up
out of nowhere
um
outer wild that's a good game
resident evil from capcom
south park the fractured butthole
great game great turn-based game mm-hmm
who's that
who's that game ain't about
uh i don't know um
i don't think fractured butthole is made
by obsidian well well it's probably what
i'm trying to say is it's published by
ubisoft and we see a lot of ubisoft
games on that list doing that sir
i mean
this list is ubisoft game these far cry
games
assassins creed
uh the crew
the division
uh so
they did them make a formal announcement
that pl uh that ubisoft plus or whatever
the hell that service is called is
coming to the service correct yeah yeah
they did they did so you know we could
talk about that for a couple of seconds
there's been rumors going around for a
while that this service is coming to
game pass ultimate uh what i want to ask
tim dawg real quick uh you know i don't
you know obviously there's more here you
guys but we don't have time to go over
all this i will uh you guys can look
this up up on your own time
uh so
with that being said we've seen all
these ubisoft games first off let's talk
about
the actual update itself you got a lot
of first party stuff going in there
they're working really good with indie
devs got the stuff like dead cells going
in there uh you know some of the dark
cloud stuff i think that's their stuff
but
with that being said
tim dawg i'm curious to hear your
opinion man do you think this is a a
solid first attempt at a rebrand to
compete with game pass
i don't think it's competing with game
pass because
there's multiple things that game pass
is doing that that's not uh
you know it has pc element involved you
can get your games on pc as well
uh day and date obviously that's the
biggest thing
um even though xbox is gonna be dry for
a while
uh if sony had day and date absolutely
would be
competing in a really strong way um i've
always said that until they match it
with the you know core
values of what game pass is
they're really kind of two different
services uh what they did here though
um
after when they announced it see
somebody sometimes steps on their feet a
little and then they you know they
readjust and then they make smart moves
when they adjusted the way they
announced it with the ubisoft uh in
their their marketing
output
earlier this week or whenever that was
i felt that's when they rebranded the
whole thing that's maybe where they
would should have went more of a you
know
a way the way they went with the way
they went this week
um you know just showing the games
showing uh
the benefits that you don't you know uh
the classics part of the um the two
tiers is is really good
uh it's a nice first step but um
to really compete with game pass uh i do
think that
um they have to uh put day and date now
with the comments of the cia the ceo i
believe
it's right now they're not looking at
that so
um i know myself and others have said
that it's it's going to happen but
um
they might not and sony is always going
to be successful so
it's possible that's that xbox should be
successful with their model and sony can
be successful with their model uh you
know depending on which does better
that's that's a whole other debate or
you know when you really look at it it's
very hard to get numbers for either or
especially from xbox
um but uh you know it's it's a start
from sony
and um i do think that they they just
you know they don't they're not robust
with the cloud
game pass you have you know games that
are you know
instantly available on the cloud
instantly available on your phone
instantly available on the console
via cloud say if you want storage space
or you just want to play immediately
uh if you want to get whatever are so
you know there's a lot of things that
xbox is uh
much more advanced and doing differently
than sony is
um but i do think sony is uh
finally got the their foot on the ground
with this and uh i do think that
uh they can definitely do well with the
subscription model
um because uh you know the the the
overall models for the year
even though you can't stack them which
sucks that's another debate
uh for the year are very good so like
for me i would probably just get the
premium
for the one what is it the the top one
is 120
or 150 i would just do that uh verse uh
or i think it's 120
first doing the monthly thing you know i
would just do the yearly one one-shot
deal
and uh you know just stay going about it
differently but uh
i think sony's now starting to uh you
know make some smart moves
yeah what about you hustle how you feel
well
to the untrained eye and if i didn't do
a little bit more reading on that
um xbox is getting ubisoft plus as well
um i think i guess it's gonna go to
gamepads as well
um if i didn't read that and i just saw
that announcement because the
announcement yesterday was just hey
ubisoft plus is coming to the
playstation um i also read i think it
was like it's like the first paragraph
tour there and they said hey it's coming
to xbox too i think it's dope that
ubisoft games are going to be available
everywhere um i do want to throw this
little tidbit in i hope that they have
cross play available just so you know if
you if you have an xbox like 10 dog you
got an xbox and if you had an xbox y'all
know our game on playstation and pc
hopefully it's cross play so if we play
a multiplayer game like steep it'd be
cool that we all can like kind of play
together you know i don't really know
how that would work but
i hope that that is a thing um or i hope
that something like that is like the
catalyst to getting everything
everybody like playing together i hope
that that happens um yeah but no but if
you didn't know any better you would i i
would have definitely thought like oh
wait this is only coming to playstation
like where is this on xbox and it's not
over there but no this this doesn't
really
compete with game pass um tim i know you
said it has to you know
uh playstation now has to have like day
one games
no no
not yet
they don't have to have day one games
yet because their games are still
selling like play blade period like i
wouldn't put my games in that service
because god of war we know it's going to
sell uncharted 5 whatever it whatever
that's going to be called we know they
sell well yeah but there is this
weird thing that people are putting more
on the cells than realistically are
there uh it's the same thing that
happens on xbox and switch occasionally
switch don't do it as much but you know
did god of war sell 20 plus million yes
they don't charge itself 20 plus million
yes did spider-man sell twenty plus
million yes
but that's a lot of killings but i have
a feeling if you take out the bundles
that is on all these consoles
you will drastically reduce all those
numbers just like xbox and switch
you're really realistically probably
looking at 11 to 12 million these games
sold by themselves without any type of
bundling uh there for a while they were
selling literally all of them bundled
like you could buy a playstation 4 that
had an uncharted four god of war and
another game bundled together and they
consider all of those games to sell like
look i'm not saying these games didn't
so well but i'm saying there's a lot of
fluffing going on there man when i make
a burger i want all that [ __ ] on the
burger i want it to okay i don't eat
tomatoes let me let me take that back a
little bit i want the lettuce on there i
want the big beefy burgers too man i
want that [ __ ] this big
it was that deal and you're referring to
that deal that was uh two hundred
dollars where it was god of war horizon
zero done and i think it was spider-man
i know it was three it was three big
titles for two hundred dollars for ogps
oh that was a holiday right yeah it was
it was that holiday deal which was a
really good deal by the way
yeah but you know what that tells me
though addict that even after all that
time when you have good product like
that people are still by your
playstation people are still by that
joint because the product was so good
those those games you know regardless of
if they fluffed quote unquote numbers
now it don't matter like all three of
them games were that good it's like oh
you could sell that for 200 and watch
the joint jump out the store place it
was going anyway but um it's it's it's
like it's like the same thing here man
let's say i'm let's say i'm selling you
something i'm i'm selling you
i'm selling you this card for five
dollars hustle okay and i'm selling you
this playstation controller for 70.
now i know
that people are going to buy this car
because it's hot
but i know people
want this playstation more
so i'm going to sell you this
playstation
470
or i'm a i'm gonna bundle it and give
you no option to buying this card with
this playstation so i'm gonna say the
playstation with this card was really
the only option you're getting them both
so you like look like i get it and i'm
not saying that's like bad i'm not
saying but i am saying there's a little
fluffing man i made you buy
five million of these cards with no
choice how many how many times have you
guys bought a abundant don't act like
these bundles aren't
aren't the
the standard
a lot of the times when you go and buy
this stuff there's a standard bundle i
remember for a long time god of war was
a standard bundle is that true or false
you go into a place a game stopper you
go into an ex
a game stop or a walmart and you buy a
playstation and it'll be a picture of
kratos his face on that back and it says
god of war bonded with that every time
someone bought one of those bundles they
they they mark it down and they're like
look man
you bought a card you bought a card i'm
gonna put this card now you bought now
some people said that the price
increased that wasn't all the time that
wasn't all
a lot of the time the price was the
exact same price and they would give you
no option to buy them individually
separately why would you buy if you
wanted the card because most of the time
people wanted the card let's be real
here people wanted the card
but why would you not buy the card with
the system for the same amount of price
so that that's all i'm saying man i'm
not saying it's a bad thing sony did
something good they made a good game so
well but all i'm saying is
i sold you a lot of cards by just
selling you a console that some of you
didn't even necessarily need i added to
your point um i bought the spiderman now
i'm saying miles morales nope i bought
the spider-man 2018 game i bought the i
bought the actual console i want the
game stop when it came the night that it
came out september 8 2018 i do believe
the night that it came out i paid 400
for that joint though i didn't excite i
pretty much got spider-man for free so i
know i i see your point man but and then
there's a couple times where i would buy
a bundle and sell the game because
already on the game like a bunch of
times yes yes i mean so that's the thing
god of war i bought the god of war um
ps4 as well that i bought that from
microsoft that game came for free as
well too so so there there are times to
where like they'll eat playstation you
know whoever right they'll eat it and
then it's like all right we really want
to move the console so we'll give you
the game so a lot of times they'll eat
eat it but if they make the profit off
the consul the game don't really matter
much anyway at that point i'm not gonna
say it doesn't matter at all but you
understand what i'm saying you'll
probably get more money from
the former than the ladder you
understand well not even probably you
get more money yes
and so you know that's all i'm saying
with the playstation plus like okay now
let me give my opinion i do think this
is a good let me take off this this
this thing man i don't like it i don't
know why
it feels like i i i'm i'm
in the
like the room so i don't know like look
i'm in a broke room i'm not an expensive
house all right look my bed's a little
messier it is what it is man all right
so look
i think this is a a good competitor to
game pass i look it's not the same
they're not getting the game's day and
date
but we have
seen xbox makes it work without those
games day and date this whole year has
been a bunch of year without a lot of
you know their true studios day and date
has anyone said game pass still isn't
value sure you're not getting your value
every month with games coming out for
xbox day and date but what you are
getting is you're getting
games like tunic and i have a feeling
sony's gonna do this you guys saw that
list
if you bought the playstation brand
for that 15 to 18 dollars a month you're
gonna get a big list of games that you
could play and i think that's where the
true value of these services come into
play
for people that don't own these games
the casual market they could pick up a
console have access to all these games
for a certain amount of time and i think
that's what makes it a value sure when
microsoft starts launching those games
in dane date of the fables the vows the
perfect arts
uh you know the outer worlds twos
that's when it's going to be a very big
competitive thing
sony might have to drop their games date
if those games are doing well they're
reviewing well and they're making that
service have a huge value in proposition
and then that's a ripple effect that
means when people go out to look a game
they're no longer looking for just
exclusive games they're looking for what
is going to give me more realistic value
in the console that i choose and when
you can go on a one and get very good
games for a subscription from 10 to 15
to 20 a month depending on if they raise
game pass in the next couple years uh
that's going to entice people to switch
to the xbox platform and play
playstation games on the side piece
when those games come out so let me get
this
super chat real quick
got a 10 super chat from donnatalk
animal crossing breath of the wild all
pokemon games smash brothers and super
mario odyssey don't get bundled like
mario kart does and they still hitting
20 million plus every playstation 4
exclusive has been bundled though
all right donna talk all right all right
let's talk about this man
how many times have i came on this
podcast that i said
people buy games on switch because they
ain't nothing else to play over there on
switch what you gonna play besides their
games
there ain't nothing else on there
i mean they got stuff but it don't run
as well but i think but really seriously
i thought well obviously we know it
don't work
unless it's stuff like
indies third parties don't sell like
that on that platform it just doesn't
uh and that's just how it is and
nintendo does what they do well they
sell their games to their audience
extremely well you gotta respect
nintendo
for the beast's nest man they go out
there and they like
got companies giant corporations coming
up to them like this ain't going to work
we need more power and nintendo looks at
them looks at the eas looks at the the
microsoft's and to some point i guess
looks at the ubisoft and said
we don't care that is some g stuff right
there and i got to respect them for that
um we got a
a ten dollar superchat from dirk
griggity what up what what's up brother
shout out to the homie
what up there
i want to point out that something i
haven't really made an announcement uh
tim dog says what's up dirk uh his his
mike's little uh in case you guys
noticed tim dog is driving home right
now i believe uh so you know uh
definitely uh i would well i'm not
driving not going home i'm i'm parked
oh you're parked you know i'm not well
yeah not in the best of situations but
i try to make it home but uh what the
l.i.e wasn't happening
be safe man be safe
uh then we got a members chat from uh
pixelbit g question many of those games
were already in ps now so
what kept it at 3.2 million and losing
subs if not the lore a day and date
playstation now really didn't have a lot
of value they didn't really market it
very well either they didn't get see
here's the difference between
playstation and game pass the day date
is by far the most single important
thing
but i think we can all agree that that
particular part isn't being utilized to
the point it could because there's so
many delays because of the pandemic
because of the uh you know i would say
there's been of a transitioning from all
these studios it probably took six
months to a year to really getting the
tone to how things should be you and
then you got to remember that microsoft
influx rated a lot of money into these
studios hired new stuff some studios got
new buildings that takes time that
delayed games too uh
and then not to mention the indie scene
microsoft went out there they got the id
at xbox program i'm sure there was some
causes and pro programs it's like look
we like your game
we'll give you more money if you put it
in game pass day and date i'm sure
that's going on behind closed doors i
don't know we ain't never talked to the
id at x pearl you know anyone know that
dude you know definitely add him on
twitter and tell me needs to come on the
iron lures podcast to discuss some id at
xbox program but yeah that's that's
besides the fact
uh you know let's go ahead and uh move
on to
the one the only
for those of you that said i had dirt
griggity i had
hustle no hustle you weren't on last
week no i had uh har get shinny i'm
pronouncing his name correct
and i had gaming forte and dark gergie
at the pretty sure i said his name we
did a good prediction show and we all
said starfield coming out this year
starfish is going to be at the
predictions which i don't think that's
changing starfield's definitely going to
be at the show
but the day later guys a day later
it was announced that starfield and
redfall is being delayed to 20 23.
what i want you guys here is first off
where were you guys at when you first
heard this information and second off
how do you think this is going to affect
xbox in 2023 i got to go get something
to drink you guys uh we'll start with
tim dawg how do you feel like this is
gonna affect
um to be honest i think it's gonna make
uh
i think that the worst of it might be
over uh they had such a reaction
a lot of fighting a lot of uh sniping a
lot of um
stuff went on uh during the week that
was pretty crazy
when you come back joel was talking
about that but
uh you know um it was ugly and uh
i think the writing on the wall is is
that
xbox you know people were saying did
they have a studio problem i think one
person said it best they have more of a
2022 problem
they really don't have a lot they have
indies
um and and smaller games stalker two is
not going to hit at the end of the year
uh the only uh
bit of faith that you can get for a
triple a exclusive
is
forza
and um that's possible that doesn't hit
this year in this calendar year either
um
i think i think xbox was in a really
good position and they were really
starting to feel their oats
and uh this is pretty much a
smash in the mouth
moment i think that uh you know i think
there's a lot of upset people
and um
uh
i felt that people acted like it's more
of a cancellation i understand people
have the right to be upset
but um
you know you also have to keep a little
bit of uh
you know
a little bit of
grounded you keep yourself a little
rounded because the game wasn't
cancelled neither game was canceled they
were just delayed
uh
and um unfortunate as it was they still
are coming out and they're probably
being better
but uh overall uh yeah they took a
pretty big hit here
uh depending on uh how the holiday goes
they're gonna have a pretty
tight holiday
if god of war comes out and does what
it's supposed to do
and
you know xbox says nothing
so uh it makes june 12th
a little more interesting even though
it's very interesting to begin with but
uh they did the smart thing getting the
bad news out because if they had done
this and showed starfield
and then after the show said it's
delayed
i think that would have really been bad
i think that's the reason i did it
yeah so um overall uh it was just uh it
was a
a lot of community members went crazy
and and there's a lot of people looking
twice it
and you know probably some people have
some regrets too because
um
that was on full display and
if you think that you weren't being read
you were being ranked
uh and uh yeah i think uh
i think i think it hit home to microsoft
and
you know uh it was definitely
called a wake-up call but their list
they always listened but you know this
was a tough bill for them to swallow and
uh
you know yeah like i said it was it was
pretty eventful week and still kind of
going you know you get that thing with
the xbox ambassador and stuff like that
um but you know
just overall it was just really a rough
pill
to swallow for them and for even xbox
fans and myself included i
i hyped the thing up i didn't think the
game was getting delayed uh i talked to
a couple people they were all on board
people who know stuff or
who have really good connections uh
people were posting dates
that were executives were posting dates
so you know
uh so uh the the the news team came
quick it came short and it was brutal
and uh the best thing for xbox to do
is uh you know take their lumps and get
these games to come out and the only way
that they can dispute any of this or
show that they're doing well is if the
stock field comes out it's a 92
metacritic and red
fall comes out and it's
you know an 86 mega critic and both are
hits
uh you'll see a lot of different takes
than what you did but overall it was a
pretty messy week and
still still uh
they're still full out from it so uh you
know uh how it's gonna take i don't know
june 12th is gonna be super interesting
indeed indeed uh
what day did this happen off you have to
tell me what day what's happening we had
our podcast on wednesday it happened
thursday that means it was
the 12th of this month
i do believe i was at work and as a
matter of fact um
i was actually anticipating uh mr morale
and the big steppers which is the newest
down by kendrick lamar i know that has
nothing to do with nothing that's kind
of what i was focused on so when i saw
that the news of starfield and radfall
getting
on the timeline i was like oh okay
um i was for my first thought was
how bad of a shape is not even red fall
because nobody i don't think nobody was
geeked up or nobody was tripping off a
red for me in the leg nobody yeah you
know that's just one thing obviously the
big title that microsoft was putting all
the time effort and energy behind you
know was starfield
and so when i saw it because they
announced it 11-11-22
you know they wanted to recapture what
elder scrolls did back in the day
nah for 11 11 11 and now man it was just
a thing and
that
chain of events spiraled into uh and tim
you alluded to it earlier like
it spiraled like out of control for
certain uh figures over that xbox um a
certain young lady in the ambassador
program it there was a lot that was
going on man i don't
like y'all y'all both follow me on
twitter y'all know i don't really get
the
trying to protect anybody who works at a
trillion dollar company or billion
dollar cup like it's just it's not in my
my thought process because the game is
delayed if if that game is delayed then
there's a reason why that game was
delayed maybe things just weren't up the
snuff i heard some rumors circulating
around or some people who i kind of
trusted saying that this was a cyberpunk
situation i put that in quotations
because i don't think i don't think it
was that bad i saw some stuff floating
around i was i saw some twitter spaces i
said no i don't think it's that bad
because they would if it was a cyberpunk
situation they would have gotten this
all the way early in the year
a point blank period hey this ain't
really up to snuff right now so we gotta
at the top of the year they would have
got that out the way so i think well
first of all i think this game is going
to come out probably february if not
march and next year a lot of people
think it's going to come up the
following year in um 2023 so like 11 11
23. i don't doubt that yeah i don't
think that they're going to wait that
long i think whatever they have to
excuse me whatever i have to tidy up
i think they want to
get rid of that quote bug says the title
i think that things may have been a
little too too rough like fallout 76 was
right
and then things may have been too rough
and i don't think they i don't think
they want a repeat of that so like hey
just push it up a little bit and i think
you know first of all we i think we get
a release date at march or excuse me
june 12th at the e3 well i say e3 at the
microsoft presentation i mean i say e3 i
got to make sure i don't say that
um
number two man it's
um and uh uh attic are we gonna talk
about the other thing after after you
get your points across about the
the what just say it um no no i'm not
almost lost i'm trying to throw about
the young lady who's the next oh yeah
we'll get to that here
there's a couple little topics i want to
talk about nothing to take time uh yeah
okay
all right so
here's what i think i do think this is a
bad look in 2022
i think it makes xbox look a very
very empty year and
look is that bad yes for 2022
um they do deserve the criticism
um
because it's not just like one or two
things it's a variety of different
things and i think
that we need to be better as a community
and vocalizing that tim dog vocalizes it
all the time hustle myself talk about
the overall community um phil spencer i
still think is the right person for the
job i do think that
he has done enough for getting all these
studios getting so many games greenlit
he's done enough to validate waiting for
the games to come out
sure we gotta wait longer we've waited
long enough and i get it and it sucks
um
let's at least wait till the june the
12th show at least
like we so close to that thing let's
let's at least wait for that um it is
interesting that they announced this
before the event
because to me you could have announced
it later on this year and not get so
much like to me right now your
primary focus
is to wait until the show comes out you
know what i'm saying
you're wanting to hype up the show
having this showed up i think
is kind of derailing the show a little
bit uh tim dawg did a mention
it's gonna be weird to put at the end of
trailers
another year so that's probably why they
did it but to me they didn't post this
which
all right all right here's my conspiracy
i'm gonna get a literally conspiracy hat
to put on
i feel like
their mindsets look
we have
things coming out this year
we're just going to go ahead and take
the hit
because we want to show another release
date
so i think this july uh june 12th i
think you're going to see a new release
date
probably january february march around
that time
because to me
if i knew a game was coming out
and i knew it was getting delayed
i would just hold on to that stuff to
the chest
wait till around
august september then delay that thing
sure
you're going to get the same hit
but at least you didn't de-roll your own
event if that makes sense
um well i don't know i don't know i
think that that listen man
if they did that i think i think it
would even be worse but but tim this
the reason i'm about the reason i'm like
you're talking about the railing defense
you're going to be the first one
did you see it did you see it you know
and i get that
you know you're gonna be watching with
every other xbox fan going crazy okay
you know we're not gonna be talking
about delays
we're not talking about that we're
talking about
announcing a delay when we've seen the
game and announcing a delay when we
haven't seen the game i feel like
if they weren't like if they just show
all if they just show 2023 now after the
thing let me uh get my point across then
i'd be a little bit more disappointed
because i feel like the delay would hit
better if they have a good showing
if they showed this game coming out or
if they just showed it during the event
the new of the new release date 2023. i
just feel like it's odd
to get this kind of bad news out the
probably the the highlight of your event
before the event came out i feel like
personally
if they show good showing in june the
12th the game looks good everyone's
excited then they hit you with the uh
then they hit you with the delay people
are going to be disappointed but you're
just
gay players
you actually know what the game's about
feel like people will be more accepting
to delay at that point
see there's two sticks in this though
your your your route is playing with
fire in my opinion because the reaction
that we got
and you would think that you know uh
the end of the world was coming i can
only imagine
what would happen if they said that they
showed us and that you know then they
they
they you know you know how all the
conspiracies start they played us
and in the case of what you're saying
you know they would go crazy now i
understand what you're saying but i just
think it's it's a play with fire i
actually feel that xbox in good faith
with the fans
did what they did and you know it was
probably a shock to them and maybe they
could have
uh done this better uh or a way of
revealing it but
maybe they could have shown some
screenshots
you know
said uh you know this and that but i do
think that they just wanted to get that
out of the way
so that they can focus on the show now
the show itself
i'm confident it's going to be very good
and
and i agree it's a little bit like it's
going to be good
but i do think that we'll all be very
excited for it but you know i just feel
like you're your way of going about it
it's it's it's a smart way of going
about it but you're playing you're
saying it it has more of a double-edged
sword like it could hurt you just easy
they'll say exactly what you said they
did they lied to us
they knew that this wasn't coming out
and they showed us this thing yeah what
happened
and and so and i want phil father
you know
i don't think i will
you know i just i can only imagine from
what transpired this week i don't know
what would happen but
that would really
in a way really talk some people and
myself included i would be like what the
hell did they do here
because they had to have known
now what happens if
if they showed
the gameplay trailer it looks good but
at the end of the gameplay trailer they
do
they're getting destroyed boy that's
worse i personally feel like if you show
people good [ __ ] and you get away with
it now
okay so okay so so you're saying i want
to take your same statement that you
said but now when they show good [ __ ]
you're still not going to be let down
you're going to be back let down but at
least
i get what you're saying like i'm not
saying that i'm right or you're wrong
i'm definitely not gonna say you're
right because then it's saying i'm wrong
but you know like i just personally feel
like if you show someone what the game
looks like finally people understand
what's going on and then people are
finally starting okay i see this
starfield game now then they hit you
with the delay at the end of the trailer
they were like damn it got delayed
they're gonna get some flack but at
least people know what they're getting
and i get what you're saying to let them
down now that way when you see it
they they already know the expectations
to going into that event but to me
the reason people are so upset is a
there's nothing to play this year and b
we don't even know what the game is to
even be
to not be excited to be excited that the
game's getting delayed
i feel like there's just a lot of mixed
mixed emotions going on because there's
no information on it like this is one of
the few games i've seen get delayed but
we know still literally nothing about it
well that's like that's that's why the
egg on the face
goes on to people like me myself who
people are right when they said tin dog
hyped the game that had no two i was
right there
had no game play and i
when i read something i said you know
that's pretty you know i can't dispute
that i'm a fair person i said i'll take
that out i says yeah that's a pretty bad
out that i did do that but you know you
you were thinking well okay it's todd
howard fall out uh they showed at d3 it
was relatively short time uh you know
there was a reasons why we did what we
did
but at the end of the day it's it's so
it's not a good look
that there was no gameplay showed
and all this went on
and keep in mind i see the chat coming
at me look me look
i'm just saying that i think i would
have took it better if i saw the game i
understand i'm not everybody just giving
you my opinion you could take it you can
leave it you can write it on a piece of
paper put it on your refrigerator and
look at it every day i don't know what
to tell you yeah um
hold on hold on
that's cap that's all cap if
you're watching the drone with the lords
i'm watching it with the laws we're
doing a live reaction right we attend
dog you there too and then after the
trailer we see
11 11 23. come on
come on let's not do that 11 11 23 it's
not gonna work
but if it's like
2 3
4 20 uh 2023 i don't think people are
flipping i think there's people going to
be upset i think the internet's going to
do what the internet does but the people
that care the people that want it aren't
gonna say [ __ ] they're gonna be excited
to play that now if it's like a six
month like seven month delay then we're
having a different conversation but if
it's only a month to two to three i
don't think the internet's gonna attack
you as much as you think they're in
there it's gonna attack them sure you're
gonna get the people that's gonna attack
normally how they attack but i feel like
if you come out there you show good
gameplay you show what this game's about
and then you say yo but we needed a
little bit more time a couple months i
don't think that's going to be a huge
huge backlash it's going to be backlash
just backlash with everything but i
don't think it's going to be like crazy
let me get these super chats real quick
all right uh because i do have another
thing i want to talk about in terms of
this so we got to let me make sure
rubber knob i i saw him
do two but i want to make sure okay we
got a rubber novel 10 super chat we all
need to stop getting angry and get about
game delays since the pandemic miss most
studios are working from push pushing
dev time to one to two years back all
games are going to be delayed uh rubber
knob what i've been told six months to a
year every game every game six months to
a year very few games
didn't get affected by the pandemic and
look
people want to say that the pandemics
aren't an excuse it's an excuse but do
you care that's the point we don't
really have to care about the excuse
we're the consumers we buy the games but
as far as the dev side that is an excuse
when you go from
everything good to everyone to a lockout
straight lockout most likely the
majority of these studios
the transition wasn't pretty going from
working at a studio to working from home
and then you got to look at the fact
that some studios are very heavy on
mocap you got studios like naughty dog
studios like uh ninja theory they do a
lot of mocap they couldn't do anything
for jeering that lockout
it is an excuse and people say well
everyone else is is is adapting fine are
they though
we don't know yet we don't want to ask
just yet return came out buggy horizon
came out buggy with a delay guard awards
have been delayed once maybe twice we
don't know yet actually it's been
delayed
it's been delayed once um
what twice no no twice
somebody said it was twenty-five
two
every game has been delayed and i get i
get what you guys are saying uh it's
like i said it's an excuse but it
doesn't matter you're the consumer you
have the right to voice your opinion
regardless but it is an excuse
uh then we got a five dollar super trap
uh
from rubber knob
from rubber knob all games like horizon
forbidden west should have been delayed
a little longer like i said the game
came out really buggy people were really
talking about that game like i said this
is a as
an issue this isn't just something
microsoft's dealing with sure some
studios have dealt with some better the
the studio that made uh ori is a
complete work from home company so
obviously companies like that doesn't
even really care and i'm sure there's a
lot of companies that had a lot of
places in play before the pandemic where
some were working from home a lot that
they were able to do it a lot faster but
this isn't one thing that fits all every
studio got to pandemicate them
differently
i don't know if you want to comment on
that tank but you can if you want
um i do think that that uh uh rubber
knob a nice name
five dollars thank you very much for
contributing to a great podcast um
i do think that the pandemic is kind of
like people don't want to hear about it
and it's very real
and it definitely affected this i do
believe that there was no covid
that we would see these games i'm
confident we would see these yeah we
would see these games so
here we are
and we were you know going crazy where
people just you know what it is xbox
kind of put themselves in this position
because
they did have a pandemic at the time
when they announced 11 11 22.
so it's on them
and believe me i talked to xbox and phil
and people and uh you know
basically
uh
they say they dropped the ball i'm sorry
in text now uh
you know they dropped the ball
and they feel very bad
and they say well they have to fix it
and
you know the only way we're going to get
to that
but you know
at the end of the day
uh
the pandemic is very real and kobut's
very real and you know uh crunch is very
real
and i mean i've seen some people say
that these people should be paid
i mean like dude you know the stupidity
that and the knee-jerk reactions that i
saw something really left a bad taste in
my mouth and i love the xbox community
and i'm the first to say it's a great
community and it's the best and this and
that you are your best when that without
that day happen in my opinion i do feel
people have a right to complain but you
know you won't feel fired
you want you know you don't want to tell
the stuff a little stuff is a little bit
too much so
uh i don't know i mean
i get the disappointment i get the i can
get the outrage but i can't get the knee
jerk reactions like
why are we paying these people you know
these people
believe me
think about it that how passionate the
gamers imagine being a developer
and this is what you have to you have to
deal with and you have to push that out
you you're living your life and putting
your life and every ounce of energy you
have into this game and you have to
delay it it sucks for them all around
too
um
i just hope we can get to a point where
uh you know the cove corbett's still
gonna be an issue but
where it's not as big as an issue and
you know these games start to really
start to release
on a uh on a good
good good amount or you know where it's
we're not sitting here for a year you
honor each other yeah kovit is an issue
and i do feel like uh first off
i feel like the bigger your studio was
the bigger your company was
the harder covet hits you because
there's more parts to interrupt
and i think that's why you saw a lot of
these smaller indie studios didn't get
hit as hard
but massive studios massive people work
five six hundred eight hundred plus
people
they got devastated by it i mean uh
normally
the uh the expansion for destiny comes
out every september they've delayed that
both years
so it's just like look like
i get it people are upset i'm upset uh
maybe not nearly as much as some other
people but it's just like as far as say
oh we need phil to be fired
phil
is doing the best he can with the tools
he has look i get it you guys want to
take anything he says as heart uh but
phil came into a studio
uh he's finally rotated the ship around
he's got all the water out but then he
hits another small iceberg known as the
pandemic
uh and that delayed games drastically
six months is not a lot in game
development but six months to gamers
is a lifetime
and look i personally i don't know how
you guys feel and i'll let you comment
real quick hustle
i personally feel until we start seeing
some of these games come out we can't
truly see if phil was the right person
or not
phil has done stuff that no other person
has done in the xbox brand no peter
moore no don matrick no one phil has
convinced microsoft to take xbox
seriously phil has got them to invest
billions of dollars into the ecosystem
phil has got them to open up money to
green light games that were not green
lighted before him phil has done stuff
that a lot of other people would have
felt is a dream sure there's been a lot
of hiccups phil had a lot of politic
democracy stuff going on when he first
came in but phil has done stuff that no
other person has done in the xbox brand
and i feel like just all that stuff that
i just mentioned is enough to at least
give this man the benefit of the doubt
until we see some of these games come
out
that's uh that's the kind of way i felt
too
um for my overall take and i didn't want
to seem like i was
being a shill or defending the company
they deserve to get beat up a little bit
here but he does they deserve the smoke
but it's giving criticism and calling
for a man's job i feel that's that yeah
and the thing is the people that call
them for a man's job these are the same
people that were in my dms saying
hail phil
he's taking over he's buying call of
division this is so amazing i love being
an xbox fan
so to me it's like i don't i don't know
if it's
the same people
i do think that if god of war god forbid
was delayed
they'd be so happy
they wouldn't care anymore so to me is
it really about the game or is it
because
the guy that you control war with and
[ __ ] with
has a one-up on you and believe me that
plays into it i hate to say it you know
uh the first thing
the console warriors were doing
and you know i i i'm sometimes involved
with it and i try to you know joke we
don't nearly do it as much as we used to
too
the whole new one
doing it but
um
those people were like the happiest like
the sony guys were you know so happy and
they were you know they were made some
of the stuff and i'll admit some of the
stuff that they put out was very funny
and like had me laughing like they got
the xbox guy
and it's like it's like sometimes i hate
to say is it does that is that more
are you really upset about the game or
is it because you're being made fun of
because you know you were saying 97
metacritic
star field and that people have it you
know that's that's what i was saying
when i was on iop
i feel bad for the people that generally
was excited for star field i wanted to
play but i can't say i was a hundred
percent i need it now i'm more like that
with fable you can ask tim dawg me and
ten dog been having this on and off
thing about fable for like that decade
it feels like but as far as the people i
love starfed i love bethesda games but i
can honestly say that when it comes to
star field i'm okay with the weight
fable a little bit different but
starfield i want to play it and i see it
but i'm okay i'm not getting up i'm
sitting on my couch man i'm waiting for
that to come to me so let me get these
uh let me get these super chats real
quick uh five dollar street chat from
too
much uh from mr two opinionated my
opinion i'm ready to watch for star
field even till 11 11 23 if it hits but
fill your lineup while we wait one game
a quarter we'll get to that here in a
second and then we got a five dollar
super chat from dead
planet uh i love the game lost planet
man i would love to change your name the
lost planet
uh series x was introduced with
hellblade 2. we've seen it twice since
2019 three years ago not to sound
arrogant but the game better be
very damn close
uh we won't go into too much into that
uh because there's not a lot of
information on that we have seen it and
we've seen gameplay so hopefully we'll
see more uh visual game playing will
come out soon five dollar super chat
from dead planet tim dawg
sony has timed exclusivity on the sh-2
remake
silent hill 2 remake thanks blooper but
apparently two other silent hill 2
projects in the works any coming to xbox
have you heard anything about silent
hills coming to xbox
haven't heard much and i wouldn't put
too much stock
into anything right now with that i know
they had the screenshots but just wait
and see what it is
all right so all right let's move on to
the last little bit of this this topic
uh just make this quick i'm gonna go to
each person on the panel
tell me two ways you think they can make
up for star field and red fall being
delayed we'll start with club x uh with
tim dawg
uh get two games from
i don't know what you can but get two
games from game pass and announce it at
day one put some money up and get some
food you know
i think that's pretty much logistically
overall what do you think hustle
i mean i wasn't even gonna go that route
i was gonna say in regards of the show
you went out to release date for perfect
dark cause you know that's what i'm
looking forward to first of all i said
you announced that and you show and i
know you like a vowel so show some of
our gameplay too like i kind of want to
see more that since we know that um
starfield and red followed me and pushed
out
you could show stuff from that but show
more show other things show other things
down the pipeline i would say that since
we know that this one thing is getting
delayed i would say show uh show a lot
of your other titles that uh you know
pull us up god forbid pull a sony you
know how they show the games four years
out well what the hell pull us on me i
think
you got to do something because
that was stuff it was y'all heavy hitter
i said was with xbox fans the ones that
they were waiting on so yeah
yeah my sense about in the middle but
before we get on with that man there's
302 people in this chat hit that like
button if you guys don't mind i wanted
to try to get that above 200 before the
end of the show probably no that's not
going to realistically happen but i love
being unrealistic my shit's in this in
the clouds man so there you go we're
gonna
i think it's in the middle i think the
biggest thing they need to do is try to
secure that call of duty coming to game
pass day and date uh if that if they're
able to achieve that it's going to be
interesting i think that you do that
maybe one more big title game and i
think if they can't get those game pass
games because it's too far i know that
there's a lot of uh you know contract a
lot of legal stuff going on they're not
able to get anything game pass
you want to make sure
that you show these games avowed
if you can hellblade um you know star
filled red fault you want to make sure
that these games look the best that they
possibly can because i'm i'm i'm
confident
if forza it forza uh jason max said it
as well uh let me put up his thing uh
i personally feel like
if you're able to show these games in a
very very positive way
where
honestly think people reason the
starfield thing hit a lot of people
because we don't know what these games a
lot of these games are we've not seen
game played a lot of these games but if
you show hellblade combat looks great
you show a very good look of star field
looks great show forza white was delayed
new engine looks great you show red fall
amazing co-op experience looks great you
show a valve awesome rpg good release
date looks great i think
people would lay off the delays
because you're showing
look
we've had a lot of delays
but we're showing you these games some
of them have release dates maybe
hellblade and avowed i don't know red
fall definitely starfield definitely
maybe more of these have release dates
than otherwise if you show people
what these games look like how they're
gonna feel and what they look like day
one let's not do none of this ubisoft
stuff free it's like you have an
illusion little thing where you know i
was making my house look like an
expensive house none of that
show us what we're gonna play make it
look good and tim dawg don't you think
people would i think that would get
people off people's back i really do
well i agree with what you and hustle uh
say uh
had said um about this and yeah that
would be the best answer
um but realistically how can it be done
supposedly it takes a team
the whole entire studio three weeks off
of the dev
timetable so if you're gonna make a demo
uh it's it's three three weeks to a
month
to uh completely dedicate yourself to a
demo and trailer that includes gameplay
so
if that had happened they probably are
are beyond that date where they couldn't
gordon coordinate it
unfortunately i think they're in court
between a rock and a hard place
that yes they could do something like
that or if they had more time they
probably could have planned this a
little bit better but
i do think that um they're kind of
caught in a rock in a hard place you're
not gonna get that gameplay that they
need
from an avowed and you're not gonna get
that stuff you might get it from another
show
down the line but just not now and as
far as the like times exclusivity stuff
or the time the
game pass day one on game pass
uh that's very unlikely too cod uh the
card is so cod and four's eight i don't
think they're going to touch cod because
they don't want to mess around with the
regulations and they're scared shitless
of that you know they don't want to you
know say oh you're already starting in
you're tinkering you know you're you're
dabbling with the the
already making changes you know they're
supposed to be hands off 100
so i think you throw that out the window
um
i as as as i kind of feel i think 2022
is going to be a
a tough year it's going to be a tough
year but it's going to be followed
by maybe one of their best years ever if
not best and it's like i said
look
at the end of the day even if the year
is a complete flop
um
none of these games come out the year
they supposed to they all get pushed
back to 2023. we have absolutely nothing
coming in 2022. it's gonna be a bad year
but as long as these games that follow
up in 2023 are good people will forget
people got short minds uh i'm not
condone i'm not like accepting the way
they did i think they should have 20 22
games uh i honestly feel like if they're
not going to give us
their own stuff they need to open up
that checkbook and get some of these
games in game pass day and date all
right let's go to these little topics i
want to talk about real quick all right
first thing y'all did you guys see that
post that was on twitter that showed all
of the stuff that playstation's
marketing but call of duty wasn't on it
no
yeah apparently it was some kind of
i saw that and call of duty was not on
it
that's interesting now maybe it's
because that's a given but there was
stuff like final fantasy on there
so i don't even know if it's that
you guys think there's a possibility if
this deal goes through that there's some
kind of deal in place where microsoft
takes over the marketing
because it's weird that sony is
marketing that game and that's probably
their biggest marketing game and it's
not on that list and everything on there
they're marketing
i always thought they had to honor
whatever contract was in place but if if
that deal does go through then i mean
from playstation i'd be like no y'all
can take that and maybe
maybe they're still marketing it but
they didn't put it on that list because
it's not a viable thing in the future
bingo there you go
they probably said you know what it's
going away next year uh
let's like kind of hold the horses i
don't think you're going to see
microsoft with the call
cod exclusivity mult uh marketing deal
again this is a regulation deal there's
this whole thing going on xbox is
shaking in their boots
you know uh a real thing is if they got
this this thing denied it would really
hurt them set them back a lot so lots of
writing on that so i don't think
any kind of call of duty i think what
you just alluded to is the answer maybe
this is the end of their their run and
they don't want to give a shine a
spotlight on call of duty because they
know they're losing it
all right so
i don't know if you want to comment on
this tim
uh there was an individual an xbox
ambassador uh that
posted uh some criticism on uh people
criticizing uh phil spencer i think the
tweet
was a little bit untasteful like i don't
agree with the tweet uh but it does look
like people went to the streets like
they normally do they brought up uh the
fact that she don't play certain games
that she says she play uh that she hypes
up now you know i want to focus on
individual uh not necessarily her but
should people that are that much like
you know
people that's that much in twitter
streets that represent a brand that
microsoft physically works with
should they play games to that degree
because even 10 dog ted dog's been a
very big xbox fan for a while
uh and if there's anything that you
could say about 10 dog you know people
might say you know tim dock shells for
the company this that and the other but
one thing you can never say about tim
dawg is he doesn't play games
and i that's what i kind of kind of want
to talk about like do you think that
a brand ambassador or anyone that truly
uh represents the game uh you know
they're constantly working with studios
microsoft acknowledges them as a partner
do you think that they should be playing
games to that degree but let me get this
super chat real quick we got a two super
chat from rd i don't want release dates
they're not trustworthy completely
understand so go tim tom
uh well almost this particular case is a
little uh weighted um i know the
individual for a long time
uh i can say that she's a
super nice person
um
and
you know the things have transpired i i
really don't feel that are
i don't think it's 100 fair because
she definitely contributed contributes
in a lot of other ways like streams
community events stuff like that i've
known her for a while
um
and she never using to me or she never
partaked in the console wars
she never i agree i i have a follower
and uh i think i don't know if she
follows me i've never seen her once
particularly number one
never once and listen if she was like
that i kind of say yeah it's open season
on somebody like that but being that
she's really kind of disengaged herself
from that
and i really never played up to it um
i just think it's unfair enough
unfortunately you know it was uh king
thrash
who was the person let me go in this
place having quiet
um
king thrash
was the person that uncovered it and
he's a sony guy and you know he wanted
to make fun of the ambassador program
uh and said you know look they don't
have worthy people
um and then you know and then kids will
lose pissed which i get i'd listen i
think that uh
the ambassador program has always been
uh you know who you know type feel type
thing but i do feel
that they uh do put their best foot
forward and try to
um
you know uh
you know have good advanced ambassadors
i i do feel like they're trying to do
the right thing uh is there a lot of
politics involved 100
i would never be able to be an
ambassador
they would say i'm too you know
really i fight too much i'm this and
that
and we're okay with that
you gotta move a certain way hustle to
to get like there's a difference between
being in like the center
and there's a difference being
professionally in the center
uh you know and it is what it is like
let me give my thing a little bit um
look i'm gonna tell you guys the same
way i did the review the only thing i
disagree with this individual is she
said that you have to run a company to
be able to criticize it i don't agree
with that yeah that's not fair as far as
people bringing up her gamer score
i get it
she i think a lot of this has to do with
him i don't know if you if you agree
with this but i think a lot of these
have to do is you got people that have
been grinding in the streets regardless
if they're doing the console or not
doing the console war uh they're putting
a lot of effort into this industry uh
they they put a lot of effort into their
channels into their twitch streams into
their twitter following they do
everything they can they play the games
they review the games and a lot of them
don't get the opportunities that the
opportunities like this individual would
get i think that's where the core of
this stands is you got a lot of content
creators and a lot of people in general
annoy that people like that get the type
of uh you know i wouldn't say pat on the
back but they get those opportunities
that a lot of people have really put
time into and don't get it and i think
that's i think that's where it's really
coming from uh
yeah let me just let me say i agree with
you i'm not gonna say that i do think
this stuff has uncovered a lot of
stuff like that and and some of that
stuff isn't fair and i 100 agree with
you um
do i think kid smooth should be an
ambassador absolutely i think that you
can look past somebody who's
had uh uh you know uh an outburst on
twitter or anything um that was real one
though
is somebody who's helped people in the
community
he's the first guy there
so for me and he's a big time gamer he
knows his stuff so i kind of get why he
would be a perturbed why he he doesn't
get it but let's be honest we also know
that microsoft
is a corporation first and foremost and
that they are going to look for that
they don't want any kind of loose ends
they don't want to have a guy where you
know they have ksi you know who ksi is
right you guys know who he is that's the
big youtuber yeah yeah
he was only with xbox
and he was like one of their people that
they were really high up on what
happened was he made some comments about
women or he um
had a viral video of his that he was uh
people would say objectifying women i
don't know it was [ __ ]
and they adopted him
and that's the thing in corporate
america and anything that you in
anything that you could come close to
you're done
and the one thing i will say for the for
the xbox ambassador who
who
has had the lights on her
she's been nothing but a model citizen
so i have to give her that much
it's hard it's hard not to get yourself
caught up in something
we don't but to me
um
we need more gamers that are women in
general we have to be more open
to women in general
on a console on video games i mean i
know how it is it's it's not
it's sometimes tough for
a woman to come into a a chat room with
a bunch of guys how toxic a lot of
people are sometimes i'll be in a party
with some of these dudes they'd be
acting like they've never heard a woman
speak they've never seen a woman i'm
like dude
i'll knock on the door next door there's
probably a woman in there somewhere like
we have a woman in the chat room let's
be honest this is real talk right now
when there's a woman in the chat room
you got six guys you always have that
one guy that's saying something
inappropriate or trying to placate
himself to the girl
and
that is unwelcoming to to to to a person
so
for me it's like a double it's like
double hit for her i don't feel like i
don't i hope that she doesn't take this
what i'm worried is that she's gonna
take this experience and give up and say
you know i don't want to want i want her
to just brush it off
i haven't reached out to her because i
know that she's probably had reached out
and
uh you know people reach out to her but
i just think that in this case it was
she was unfortunate
uh bullseye for people that you know are
looking
not to just just to discredit xbox and
other things and she she came up did she
make comments that maybe
uh
let the wolves so hard maybe but at the
end of the day
uh i i don't think that she should i
think she should we're very worthy of
being a ambassador doesn't always mean
you have to play video games i mean if
you look at it and be realistic
some of the guys that we love on xbox
don't play that much xbox jim ryan you
think he really plays much playstation
you think that these guys herman's helms
are coming home like us
and playing games till three in the
morning and chats no they're going to
sleep with their family
so the you know the bottom line is is
that you can't in my opinion judge a
person
by what games they play or the duration
that they play if they're playing and
they're making a good effort that's all
that needs to be said and they have to
be knowledgeable and i think in the most
part we have people that are super
knowledgeable here and we don't have
stupid people that are completely
clueless it's one thing to be
knowledgeable
and it's nothing to be completely
clueless that you can't help somebody i
think in this case she's very
knowledgeable that somebody came to a
problem with her she would understand
how to get it rectified and fixed
yeah and it's like it's like i've said
like i understand people are upset you
know i've never really got into that
like fraud stuff like i don't really
care but i understand it's like i said
people
people are tired of people representing
a gaming community that don't play games
and i get that
uh but she does a lot of positive in the
community that you don't see you know
the diversity she tries to bring more
women to the community it's just like
look at the end of the day
should she promote games that she
doesn't play no but some of you promote
stuff that you don't do either and all i
the only thing i it's like i said only i
don't agree with her is how she said you
have to run the company to do it uh
people were saying i don't know i didn't
see it myself that people are attacking
her for being a woman people attacking
her personally none of that
and that could be anybody you know like
it could be a stock xbox guy that's a
listen
there's people in the ambassador program
right now that hate her okay
it's not it's just not like xbox like
there's a real big debate going on about
this because
there i know the ambassadors those
people
are very tough on people i remember doc
doc
who i felt at the time was worthy of it
um or he was
to be considered they didn't they didn't
allow him in um it's very hard to get
into it and uh
it is kind of a
you know
a big deal
um but that community is not an easy
community so
i'm sure
she's getting it from both sides is what
i'm saying she's getting um the fanboys
she's getting it from just like people
like us who are just considering what
she's saying i'm not me but
you know like just people who question
her and then she's also getting it from
the back end from the people who she who
her peers are and that's very real and
again i just don't want it to be a point
where she just she busts she's been
she's been holding strong so
that's unhappy about it but it's it's
kind of ugly yeah i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna deny it it's pretty pretty rough
and people weren't nice to her and some
of the stuff like i said she might have
opened herself up to
um
but i just think that
uh we also you know should consider some
of the good stuff she does too
it's like i said
i don't i'm never gonna uh condone uh i
mean i'm never gonna agree with any type
of like uh dog piling any type of
harassment none of that because i do
feel like people need some form of a
safe space on the internet but at the
same time the moment you sign up to be a
public figure you're going to get
subjugated to this uh i hate it for but
um
i have had this happen to me multiple
times and i'm sure you had had a 210
where it's like
she's grateful not to have had this
happen or up until now
uh but it's just like we all need to
improve the people that attacked her the
people that uh you know could have maybe
criticized her a little bit more
respectfully i'm not going to tell you
how to criticize people
i feel like you might have been able to
uh there's ways to criticize people
without sounding like a dick
and then she can improve the way she
presents information uh you know maybe
not to cat for games she's not playing
because i do understand where people are
coming from uh but at the same time uh
she's never really come out there acting
like a hardcore gamer either like i've
never seen her i've never seen her post
on there you always put 80 hours into
well she's never also partaked in the
console war too and she was dragged into
this
um
i guess because she she said something
and somebody you know i mean thrash i
like trash me and him are cool but you
know he's definitely uh
he has a bone to pick with xbox and he's
checking people's gaming score um i
don't know to me that's a little bit
much uh uh you know i think the the
ambassadors can control themselves or
they could they can monitor themselves
they don't need somebody who care less
about the brand and wants a brand to
fail
to you know get this girl and put her
out there and and and just you know
like you say have everyone dog pile on
her i don't know for me
i just get defensive of that because i i
know how uh
how you know a lot of times
just women in general are
with the video game community are uh you
know treated differently or guys act
differently or they say so that's just
the truth of the matter and we should as
a whole want
to just be more respectful and welcoming
to
everyone you know the the core
hardcore gamer guy whatever you want to
say
that guy's a pretty tough [ __ ] you
know what i mean if you know what i mean
like
they're not easy to deal with they're
gonna be they're gonna have hard takes
and they're going to be passionate and
they're going to be the guys that are
going crazy on twitter you know yelling
at microsoft so it's not an easy
place to be if you're somebody who's
just in
not that way
it's like i've always said tim
when you look if you see someone that
says something on twitter you don't
agree with yeah that's why you don't
really i commented on that time because
uh because like i said i didn't agree
with the statement uh but you don't see
me commenting when a reviewer doesn't
beat a game or a reviewer plays 10
minutes of game you know what i do
hustle
i never see that person's review ever
again if you don't like this individual
you don't like a reviewer you don't like
someone in the industry that's giving
you a product that you don't like and
you think they're being ingenuous just
unfollow them don't give them any more
power don't like their posts because all
you're doing is putting spotlight on
them and giving them what they need to
succeed even more but you know go ahead
and hustle go ahead and give your
opinion on this because i know tim's got
to go yeah yeah tell me i'll make it
quick um that's your home girl and that
that's cool and everything it's
it's more about something like this i'm
an xbox ambassador like but the
requirements to get that is like super
low like just be cool no she is a real
[ __ ] okay i thought you meant like
what did you do you saw what everybody
else was doing that you see on like the
youtube where you got that 1500 thing
that's just something that they do on
that like she's the elite of them am i
right tim yeah no this this xbox
is real like they
they're backed by um
you know a certain group and you know
when you're you know it's a pretty
illustrious group
and it's hard to get into that smooth
has been trying to get into it for years
all right all right well let me say this
let me say this tim them your people
tell her checkered dm you tell her wrong
with me we can play some gears five meet
her in the troubleshooters we can ask we
have a good time the i don't i don't
agree with the harassment all right
that's you know uh you know it's
unacceptable like yo nobody should be
treating whether she's a chicken
xbox mvp that's what they think that's
why okay
all right
nobody should be harassed based off of
this however you can't make a comment
like that like you got to be careful i'm
okay
you're right because i'm getting to the
point where like i'm doing this and like
and that you know like a lot of people
starting to oh who's this hustle guy oh
let's go ahead and check them out hey
look i might be five or seven games a
year but i don't have no problem putting
that out there right this there's no
there's nothing for me to have my
trophies ain't here ain't none of that
other stuff is hitting there everybody
know what it is with me everybody know
how i get down everybody know what's
authentic with me
that's the difference like a lot of
people have that stuff but i do want to
say no um i i disagree with this young
lady i'm not gonna slide but i didn't
slam to her even when she posted all
that i don't know i just said yeah nah
cause that that's that's corny that's
that's mad calling to me anyway cuz like
a lot of people who was doing that
wouldn't set it toward no way um
wouldn't set it to her face no way but
that's that's like
extremely childish she's like that's
that's that's
i'm gonna watch my mouth that's
sucker-ish to me but you know whatever
if you don't play the game like look
just play the game like i felt like she
was almost bullied into doing something
that she kind of sounded like like 100
right there you saw that yeah but like
but just you know it's cool like even if
like because sometimes i can only get
like maybe three hours a game and then a
week but it just be like that sometimes
we grown like everybody's grown we got a
full-time job bro i'll be surprised i'm
doing this because i wake up so early
eric you know this i become so early in
the morning it was like yo i'll be i'll
be having like the energy to really like
do all this right
i do want to say this though um to the
people over at xbox who are doubling
down and tripling down on on defending
this young lady
okay that's capped up and they know what
i'm talking about man that's that's
that's cat blood you can't do that you
you can't you can't accept that baby i
understand that this young lady does
other everything different i know she
does she different positive things for
the community ah look that's that's cool
that's my fact that's great and we need
more people like that around but yo like
listen you know the only i only play a
handful of xbox games and that's like
halo and gears like when perfect dark
and all the mother joints roll out yeah
i'm running them too but
yo play them at the very least like
get you like you know maybe 50 hours in
each like it's not it's not hard bro
where i felt back was into getting like
50 hours in the hello infinite with
erica no you see me playing and
struggling and whatnot it's only like yo
just a couple hours dog like just just
play the game for a little bit and
look i know i know you're whatever her
job is it's probably demanding but
yo i like i play the games the unwind i
got galaga back behind me after we leave
here i'm gonna let the dogs in i'm gonna
play gallagher for a little bit before i
watch wrestling like it's just just one
of them things like this is something
that you should do that online but
i mean i don't know look look i didn't
see her being harassed in that thread
i'm not i'm sure she's not lying about
it because somebody can just go through
that thread and
people need to realize too just because
you didn't see it in a thread doesn't
mean people are demon hurts them off the
wall
and that's probably what i uh beat her
i agree with what you're saying you have
to you have to
hold your words a little better than
maybe she said some stupid things but
when you are let me let me say this when
you are under attack
like she was
um
you're gonna try to
make a point for yourself and i think
that's maybe why she ran into some
trouble
um
i think i think uh hustle you you you
have great advice
and uh maybe if she watches she could
that's great advice to listen to
um
i do think though that you know uh
you know if
if the if if the
you know like because i know some of the
community of the the mvp
they gotta outline what requirements and
yeah you probably should have a
certain amount of gaming hours and you
know you shouldn't really talk about
stuff maybe they make them requirements
but you know
i don't know her whole story
but uh you know it it's it's just been
an unfortunate one because like i said
what that's me is that it would have
it probably would have never happened if
you didn't have
such theatrics going on i just kind of
felt like she caught up in it and i kind
of feel bad and i admit it maybe i'm i'm
uh
uh too guilty of that because
you know she she was never involved with
the console war so this is all new to
her like and she's probably it's
probably alone
and
you know
you know but like i think i think you
gave great advice and
maybe she can do stuff like that or you
know
uh you know don't talk about it just do
it and just uh you know move on and
things will work itself out and i do
want to say this you know one more time
like to the people who are defending her
i mean of course you defend her against
the harassment but
hey look uh
it start
you know
it starts
and i got a playstation but i don't know
maxwell's controller but let's start
with this just pick the troll update you
know just get in as much as you can but
just start with that and then
phil expensive from you know from what
and tim maybe you can speak to this
better than me and i could try to hold
you up too long but
he's he he gives off the he like he's
the type of dude like who he's he's held
himself accountable on multiple
occasions
all the time yeah so like he'll really
help me that defending for referral like
i understand like i i get it because hey
look i defend my people all the time i
defend my folks all the time
you know that but
you don't need it
you know the troubleshooters don't need
it like these other people they don't
need it but i mean i'm just like
i respect the loyalty and i respect the
fact that she did that but you know
sometimes you gotta you gotta sit some
conversations out it's okay it's okay to
set the conversations up i said
sometimes you have to send some
conversations out and i think that that
applies here but again like i said maybe
she was just not in the right state of
mind but
uh overall
i've been an eventful week um and
i i have to say the podcast i'm very
surprised uh was was awesome i'm not
surprised it's awesome i'm just
surprised that we had such a really huge
out like
over 300 people showing up yeah you know
really good numbers uh and uh
just uh guys thanks for having me on i
gotta get going uh
tim i appreciate you coming tell the
people where to find you at man i'm sure
they know you always follow me on
twitter i'm on uh
maybe i'll get maybe i'll do a podcast
when i can get on a a camera and uh
proper stuff right now i'm sorry i had
to do this on the phone but i've been
talking about where i'm walking down
here and uh
i that the my traffic on the l.i.e just
wasn't permitting it so i detoured to my
mom's house
all right man just be careful getting
home man
i love y'all make sure y'all follow tim
dawg thank you we appreciate it
all right so let me go ahead and get
these uh super chats real quick and then
we're gonna head out here
um
no
uh oh gotta find out superstar from 108
dragon tv what's up hello sir one away
we might have to get you on next week
man we might have to get you on next
week
all the toxic people get all uh get all
the attention let's be honest the bs
sells peeps doing the right thing don't
get the attention we deserve all facts
it's like i said man um
i don't think she would i don't know if
he was saying she's a toxic person i
don't think he was
no no but it's just like look like
when it comes to hurts it's like
the biggest thing i have 108 when it
comes to her
it's like there's one thing from
using your platform and choosing not to
speak and it's another thing to use your
platform and tell people to shut up
so uh you know that's the biggest thing
i have and i know you weren't talking
about her one-night dragon that doesn't
sound like you uh i was just uh clearing
up so people in the chat knew you
weren't talking about her because you
know how it is man people were reading
super chat they they on twitter one away
dragon was saying she was toxic that
didn't happen the super chat clearly
didn't say that um
then we got a five dollar super chat
from uh
from 108 dragon let's be real some dudes
go too far there are weirdos you can
give constructive criticism without
disrespect that's exactly what i was
saying uh and that's why i bring up like
when you move in these like uh
sponsorship streets like you could be
you you just have to be it respectively
you can't come out there and call people
off the wall stuff because people aren't
gonna they ain't gonna mess with you you
guys remember i used to have a clipboard
of saying some off the wall [ __ ] to
people in my comment section that would
come at me i no longer have that
clipboard because being around iop
cognito king saul they showed me like
look you can say what you want you just
got to be respectful and after a certain
amount of time uh you know you pick it
up then we gotta find out super chat
from uh
what fate
facio double o seven is it i think
that's feasil five zero double 007 it's
part of her job description to play
games and to finish certain games is
part of her job description to play
certain games if i have different
obligations to promote the brand it
might be hard i don't know if
she's obligated to play games because
they're not really clear on the
what it takes to be part of the
brand association like that um maybe
that's something else because like
regardless
you can debate that this chick
should be where she is you can debate
that
but i will say one thing there is plenty
of
especially women
that do play these games are not toxic
that could use that position
uh and i'm not saying she doesn't
deserve it but i am saying it's weird to
to be like in a brand and stuff like
that on stuff you don't play that's
that's the only thing that doesn't make
sense to me uh now obviously
she could be doing stuff in the
background that validates that position
but we don't know that you know she does
a lot of stuff with diversity uh you
know bringing women more to the
forefront when it comes to these type of
conversations the gaming community
itself uh maybe that's what's more
important to her than anything else like
because
you know if you look at her twitter she
don't really sure she might post a tweet
about a game but i don't really ever see
her out there act like she plays these
games like that i think if she was it'd
be a different story and i can
understand people saying like i said
there's probably more people that are
more self-suited for that kind of
position but they don't have it because
uh you know individuals like her that
don't really play these games get it but
at the end of the day
it's like um
jimmy b gaming from weapon well i was
watching this stream last night uncle
jimmy my boy he said
if you guys have an issue with people
like her getting that spot grind
yourself and take it spot with yourself
yeah that's the only row of the only
real thing i can tell you if you got an
issue with her getting because i don't
really care if she gets to be honest
with you guys i don't
uh nothing she does is gonna make me
sleep less uh we're in completely
different spaces and i am definitely not
in
the ambassador program
uh but
wait wait do do i have time to push back
on that just a little bit yes okay cool
cool i think the the biggest issue of
something like that with what her
actions like exhibit i wish tim was
still here so i can tell him too
it's like a lot of times people got
influence right
you got to imagine
some way somehow she got more influence
than hustle right so if
so if something's being done like this
like this is the person who has more
influence than me this is the person who
may have more influence over like you
know i love guess guess five right this
is this is the person who has more
influence over gears five and don't even
play it like you understand what i'm
saying so like this there's a certain
like line with that and i don't agree
with certain tactics you know getting
their game score and all that i i get it
but i don't
you know i feel like there's another way
we could have just kind of like
though i think
it's like i said the core of the issue
as people been grinding and are upset
people
that don't put the effort to learn these
games
are not
in the forefront when it comes to these
kind of conversation i think that's the
core issue people like erica for the win
she plays these games she does all this
stuff but she
never gets opportunities like that and i
think that's the core exam and i'm not
saying erica was out there on twitter i
don't think she really cared uh but she
did a video on it but she did it but
she wasn't doing anything that you saw
on twitter all i'm saying is
we can
be respectful you can criticize
respectfully if you don't like that she
has that opportunity and she doesn't
play the games go out there and do it
yourself uh because i'm 100 with jimmy
it's first off it's not easy to get in
that door
she was probably in the right time at
the right uh the moment to the right
time yeah two once you're in that
position you'll be surprised how hard it
is to keep it
uh that well that's that's not really
the surprising thing though i think the
the easy well the easy part is getting
it and it could have been a time and
thing it could have just been like hey
you know
i've been working
yeah it really very well could have been
anything i said i got my i got my job
that's hanging my current job or
whatever like i literally knew somebody
who knew somebody and now i'm getting
paid when i'm getting paid or whatever
but i know it's one of them things but
like yo we'll talk about influence and i
saw you know
a few people who i respect you know
defend there a little bit and
i don't know if you saw like the whole
checkmark twitter thing did you see that
at all
i saw it and i was like
the thing is
when it comes to
people
that defend like look like i get it
but that's that's just how they roll on
twitter like you gotta can keep in mind
some of these people on twitter they
getting heat 24 7. i see and they are on
that standpoint and i don't agree i
don't i feel like she should be
criticized for her statements
uh now
i personally don't feel like she's ever
been vocally uh attacked like that on
twitter and i don't i i hate to use the
word attack but
what it was there's an army of people
coming at you let's be real he's an
attack yes
twitter people she's just not used to
that it's like i said me
that happened to me last week
like
it happens to me a couple times a year
i'm pretty used to it hopefully from now
on she'll choose her words better
because i don't think she should lead
the the program she does enough in that
she she yeah at the end of the day
she
validates where she's at off the
community that she has uh established
and that that's all that matters uh you
know it's like i said you guys you guys
disagree
go out there
try to be your uh try to get on to that
ambrosia team by yourself it's not gonna
be easy i mean and i'll just say this
and that's why the quote like for me
from me from hustle like that's why the
kid gloves were on because i took a look
and as to what she does and this there
are a lot of other things but but again
in my mind she wouldn't even worry she
said what she said she shouldn't have
said it it is what it is you're assuming
people are defending my issue yeah my my
issue was like people doubling and
tripling down on that like yo no no no
the first thing we should be very vocal
about yeah like it's one thing to say to
defend her it's another thing to tell
people they're overreacting yeah
and it's like look like
it's bg extra on twitter yes
but bg was not wrong for most of the
stuff he was saying i didn't see it at
all he said don't give me a tweet or him
threatening people because i didn't see
that
no you get what i'm saying yeah i know
what you're saying i'm just saying bg
just came out there
sure he could have worded it a little
bit different but this is bg we're
talking about he said yo how is she a
brand ambassador and have the eye in the
spotlight of microsoft and she didn't
even play their games
that's all she said and people was
adding them over and he now and that's
the thing like he now wrong because when
i saw the thing about the controllers i
was like yo i was like yo my my thought
was yo please stop
like you don't gotta
it's just certain things it's just
certain like it's i understand like
maybe she was back into a corner she
panicked or whatever but like at the
same time no
you know you really wouldn't be in this
position like you know halo out yo they
think this many people is they can get
on that joint we keep in the world and
then that's that no shot at halo anthony
i like halo infinite now i stream the
joint last week or whatever cool
you're not wrong for supporting her if
you like the content she gets out
support her follow her on twitter if
you're not already followed her and
support the movement she goes
i'm not saying that she doesn't justify
being in the position she's at all i'm
saying is a she was rightfully
criticized for the statement she made on
twitter and b
she
probably should
choose those words differently and c
which probably should have said made c
c
at the end of the day she is
on twitter
promoting a brand she doesn't play and
look
it's like i said if you feel like that's
wrong which i don't care i don't but if
you feel like that's wrong go go do it
yourself and you know be that person
regardless how it goes regardless if you
get it if you don't get it uh she's
there because of the people she most
likely met and the statements that she
holds
and that's all that goes to that but you
know we're gonna go and rap on that i
feel like we've talked about that
forever i'm tired i still gotta ask you
a game
i forgot is there any last thing that
you want to talk about uh last thing in
that
nah nah nah i gotta read i got my
thoughts off i'm gonna expound on those
thoughts uh saturday so all right
definitely uh where is saturday your
stream
yeah on my i do a saturday stream um i
don't know the name of it yet but i do a
saturday i'll do saturday
are you with that all right
but all right so that's all i'm saying
man like i said when it comes to the
individual
support if you want don't support if you
want uh it doesn't matter what you do
man uh
all i'm saying is being do it
respectfully man do respectfully but
we're gonna go ahead and shut this down
probably gonna have 108 dragon all next
week uh see you yes
we have a good little good little uh
time
108
the cousin man
you do a good job
on
on uh the iop so i don't think i have
too much to worry about you man but the
custom uh next wants to know what time
is your stream
it will be at
either 12 p.m eastern standard time or 1
p.m eastern standard time depending on
when i wake up but i'm trying to i'm
going to try to make it a 12 o'clock
thing to get it out of the way at the
top of that you're gonna have to do
better on the giving people an hour
duration i know i know i got to make
sure i can get it hey listen listen
follow me on twitter and i'll make sure
i'll put out another video like i will
and i'll just let you know i'll let i'll
let y'all know like the schedule on the
saturday streams
okay two dollars super chat from do vi
uh probably butcher that it's why we're
gonna move on am i missing something
anyone could be an ambassador anyone
could be an ambassador on that website
but this isn't the same thing it's not
the same thing and that was my mistake
when she had mvp i figured she held a
high ranking title
but i just thought i didn't know like
what the competition because i know i
said i'm an ambassador over there and
that's why when smoove when he applied i
thought he applied for the same thing
that i did so i was like wait a minute i
was more confused smooth has been banned
off to uh xbox live before good lord
so uh we gotta i was gonna you didn't
have to do that i was about to read that
one we got two last pictures from 108 i
don't curse on my channel either i
didn't say you cursed i was just saying
because i know sometimes i let it slip
and i'm trying to do better i'm just
saying you know i'm trying not to cuss
man because if you start cussing eight
i'ma start cussing and then we're all
gonna start cutting the limit i can't do
that i gotta be the better person if you
are contributing to my cousin we all
gonna be cussing fools around here but i
appreciate ever coming out we're gonna
have 108 dragon all next week
i love having the guest already because
i don't have to worry about that next
week but i appreciate ever coming
through man hit that like button if you
guys don't mind we didn't get to 200 but
you know like i said i was reaching for
the stars i knew i was going to get the
stars but everybody go follow to a
hustle on twitter show up to that
saturday stream and until next week this
is the attic show and we